foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what's going on guys
I really like the vibe this title
screen's giving I'm not gonna lie
foreign
first off shout out to uh you know they
sent me over a review code for this
sadly I had a lot of stuff going on
couldn't couldn't get to it at the time
but you know most the time when people
send me stuff or us stuff in general
I really I really want to make sure that
I get to it and you know I I still might
review the game right now I don't know
what to see how I like this stream
if I like this stream
I do might know Life the game
oh no
[Music]
[Applause]
it's mad loud
let me be me though
[Music]
so we're about to see man we're about to
see let me turn down the music a little
bit on this end
so I'm not so you guys can hear me a
little bit
I don't mind if I'm red in a little bit
a little bit on the mixer
as long as I'm not busting your ear
drums
you know but Christopher Wright I can
bust your drums you good man you good
I saw I
work it says we recommend
playing dead cells with the controller
uh so I got an Xbox controller for that
matter I guess I could have used a dual
sense controller to see if there's like
a lot of support on that
I don't really want to play with the
Dual sense to be honest with you though
all right
play
Castlevania Unforgettable characters and
Gothic settings have arrived in dead
cells a gateway to a striking cast has
appeared and an opposing Warrior called
Richard asked you to help him vanish the
great Evil Within enticed by the
promises of a new loot rather than the
sense of morale of Duty you seek out
through the grounds and Corridor of the
gothic Castle to find and kill this
mysterious Dracula
14 iconic equipment the vampire cat
alternative soundtrack of 60 original
Castlevania tunes and 12 classic tracks
and the dead cells style two biomes
three boss fights 20 outfits and a
hidden Richard mode where you'll play
where you'll play with his
sympathy of the night my moveset
is this style of dead cells I don't know
I I don't think it is but I might be
completely wrong
[Music]
we got to find out though
it says loading
oh
[Music]
I don't I don't know all right we won't
it's probably a mess up on my end
we about to check this out though Chad
we about to check this out bro
no I don't
I played a little bit
of dead cells when it came out but I
didn't play a lot
looks like I have a bad time with it I I
still
like I remember the gist of this I just
don't remember the actual
okay
[Music]
be strange come back home for Dad
you have noticed you can no longer die
imagine what it would be like to not be
able to die like I know some people
might think that that would be a good
mindset but I don't
think that would be horrible
so we got a beginner's bow and a wooden
shell
part of me feels like range would be
very beneficial
but I'ma take the shield
can I take both
oh no you have to set we want the sword
I remember that being like the
checkpoint
oh
oh hold up
[Music]
yeah get out of here
all right we gotta do that better
[Music]
oh
yeah I do but I'm trying to get better
at pairing I feel like games are just
getting waved
more you you you pair you die
[Music]
oh
I like the filling of this game
classic I like the
soundtrack two is pretty lit
how
now keep in mind guys I've never played
dead cells like to this degree
I remember I I I oh
I tried it out but I never really sat
down with it
we got us some money
yeah yeah yeah
we don't need bows
we don't need bows what is this
absorbs 75 damage
stunts blocked enemies last longer for
Perry's successful
you know what let's try it let's try it
[Music]
yeah I came right through that door
pay the tribute how do I pay the tribute
oh I need like I need a bunch of money
I'm definitely broke and you're doing
that
uh we'll go up Health right now
I feel like we could really use health
oh yeah it was uh I forgot all about
that it was this game
[Music]
yo low-key that
low-key let's keep it row guys that dude
you know the fact that he he he uh
he stole his review helped that dude's
Channel more than he realistically could
have done by himself like that's the
best type of
of what's more I'm looking for that's
the best low-key Market you can ever
have someone at a a Prestige website
like IGN
like stealing your stuff imagine the
views that that dude got in a matter of
a couple months the amount of people
that was willing to help him grow his
channel because of that disaster that
happened you know I'm sure rajin hated
it you know I hate that for him but I'm
sure IGN hated that stuff man
you know I don't make good enough
reviews for people to start stealing my
stuff
my reviews you know I'm working on them
try to try to improve it but my reviews
aren't to that caliber yet
ain't nobody trying to steal that stuff
from me what is this
foreign
quicker
I'm the collector I'm about the closest
thing you'll find a decent company
around here bring me sounds you got them
from others in exchange I produce a few
useful items for you should you stumble
onto it bring it to me I'll introduce
you to the same experimental items
hit the health blast
[Music]
mutations
all right so I haven't found no
mutations hold up
all right
so we got mutations here
now unfortunately we spent a lot of our
money
so I don't think we're really getting
anything like that
what is this oh it's the potion
[Music]
of The Condemned
I'm probably about to get rocked in this
place Chad realm who's who's beat this
game tell me if I'm about to get robbed
jeez
[Music]
oh God
oh he teleports
how's that fair
[Music]
the teleport versus the road
no
[Music]
take it man
all right here we go one on one ow
I I don't I'm assuming I got to play a
little bit of the game for the
castlevaney castle does anyone know how
to get to it
[Music]
I'll go straight into it
I'm in the expansion but I think you got
to do a little bit of the game before
you can get into it
[Music]
I don't even know how to get to any of
these things
[Music]
oh what is that
we gotta check that out
you got a Spartan sandal blueprint
yeah project I I am in the expansion I
just got to you know I got I gotta I
gotta Breeze myself into it man you want
me to put me in there with vampires out
the gate project
you hate me that much
oh God
get up
foreign
he's getting he's getting help from one
of those little Idol things
and keep teleporting
get up
thank you
run run
get away from me
oh he can come after me no
oh man
I just assume they may castlevanio for
trca
so I'm dead
foreign
have you noticed how things change each
time you pass through I've only done it
once so I couldn't have noticed that
one thing is the island is alive it's
ridiculous what you say
okay we gotta go fast
we gotta go fast
that door closes
[Music]
we need that
we gotta go fast
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up
I got places to be
okay I can't get up there
[Music]
I don't got time to be messing with you
guys
go
[Music]
let's pick it up go go go go go go go go
get job geez
act like you never fallen from before
oh I just completely wasted time there
[Music]
go go go go
I went the wrong way
[Music]
out
oh I'm not gonna make it
all right I think that opened that door
[Music]
we're going for that health
we gotta go
oh
I don't know what these These Blueprints
are
chat enlighten me tell me what These
Blueprints are
I don't know what I just got there
either
we gotta go
what is this
oh
we're definitely not making it to that
it's a roguelike I get it man I'm trying
are you serious
don't you have to do that to like the
menu
[Music]
I don't know what this came from
I'm a little bit
playing this from like the start
because at least I'm getting stuff that
you wouldn't normally get
[Music]
we doing that mutation
let's let's let's get that potion on
yeah I I guess you would have to do it
at the menu because that's in that where
that code is say I'm too I'm too young
to know what you know to I know what the
joke is with that but I'm too young to
like really
get that inside joke with the code
oh I like this thing
[Music]
we got to kill this
shoot him
see that's how we do things
we do have the guest
s
I think you guys will be interested in
the guests
you know how it is though we'll always
make the the show
good even if you guys ain't the biggest
fan of the guests
[Music]
oh
okay I'm feeling that
foreign
[Music]
got all my health
what is this
[Applause]
show them
show them my minion
um my gamer tag is
um
what do you mean like my Xbox or Steam
because I'm playing this on Steam
veinedrin this permanent Rune causes uh
causes climbing veins to grow
I don't know if I was oh
okay
a little bit of metrovania going on
there I see
okay now I see where people come with
this
well I'm glad I didn't eat that now I
can eat it
roguelike with metrovania
you know I I definitely I think I fought
one boss
and and uh in this game back in the day
I love not doing absolutely nothing
and everything gets done for me hold
this
this oh this this dude there you go
you gotta
oh
that thing takes a lot of damage
that's why we that's why we get rid of
people
[Music]
get up
we can't lose
[Music]
yeah we'll do that I'd rather to recover
health every time I kill someone
[Music]
all right I think I'm fast
yeah how you feel idiot
show them shoot him
[Music]
we fight
I ain't messing with you
[Music]
[Applause]
oh you need a Gardener's key
I don't know where Gardner's key is ow
[Music]
oh
I can make that
okay what's out here what's this thing
protection
we're gonna kill it though
just to be on the safe side
feel free I give you guys permission to
backseat game on this
it doesn't really bother me if you guys
want a backseat game on this particular
game
yeah I don't really
see how I do backseat gaming is if I
don't like the the the the the stuff
that you guys are spewing I just won't
listen to it
yeah we need that health
foreign
go ahead and um
someone Google it find out if there's a
way to get to it
I'll be about to like beat the game or
anything that would be
that'd be a little annoying
oh
yeah fight that thing
come on man
can you fight me
no
[Music]
come on
I go lie to you guys I'm feeling this
I'm feeling this a little bit
[Music]
all right so now we got 23 cells
present uh
preserves up to 500 when you die all
right so when I die I keep 500 of my
dollars let's let's do that
I feel like that's that's important
that's worth it
[Music]
uh
how do I Parry maybe I should have
maybe I should have looked at that
yeah let's
let's get that back
so I was four seconds away from getting
that
I don't even know where I am
man this is creepy
oh it's in a loop oh man
there you go
ow
[Applause]
yeah shoot him
[Music]
customization of this product where I
Look to custom mode okay
[Music]
all right we gotta stuck oh this dude
sees us
we gotta go for him
[Music]
we gotta go for him too we need more
Health back
all right come on
I don't want them both to see me
going for more health
[Music]
that thing is so broken
like lose not
[Music]
I guess we'll go down
whatever this thing is oh it's got a
yeah we killing that from a distance
there you go
looks like something from Metroid
oh what is that
all right
[Music]
whatever it is is dead
I guess the thing doesn't shoot if
you're in a shooting
I'm concerned
let's teleport back to the thought
foreign
yeah take care of that thing
we ain't fighting that are you serious
all right let's see how to get to the
Castlevania part
how to access
Castlevania DLC and that's it
once you load in dead cells from the
menu begin your run by starting the
level in the prison cards that the
screen will freeze is a swarm of bats
fall across the streams and stuff in
case the DLCs began
[Music]
hold up
yeah so I do have to get a little bit
further into the game
we're gonna pick up that 500 though
[Music]
look at this behold your collector and
have lit flies above
you're working on it aren't you
I don't know what this is
[Music]
oh
my God
[Music]
okay get on top of them
the right motor that's what I do you
kill things
okay so he's just keeping track of all
the
things I kill okay
[Music]
oh here it is
oh what is this
we got the blood sword
ow
l
yeah you thought you had something there
didn't you
don't have nothing
what's a car's treasure
you have I just just wanted your dad a
little cars okay
foreign
we're gonna stay away from them we got
this curse on us we don't want to get
killed in one hit
all right
yeah kill him
did you just knock him off
oh
I love how they just throw you they just
throw you across the map
they got zero chill
how do I get that
[Music]
foreign
always can use money
appreciate everyone for coming through
man
[Music]
all right so maybe I shouldn't have
spent a thousand on that
[Music]
to try
you got nothing for me Fam nothing
[Music]
thank you
oh that's funny
[Music]
what is that
that's one of the biggest benefits to
coming into dead South so many years
after it's come out uh and like really
taking the game serious is I I think
there's probably a lot of stuff that
wasn't in the initial game that I have
access to because I waited
[Music]
give me this
it takes so much damage
that blood sword again
oh so it holds them for a certain amount
of time okay
yeah
I think my best best to learn how to
Parry in this game
[Music]
so you said that I'm not capable of
pairing I just don't like doing it
what does this do
okay
[Music]
oh what is this
is that that chick
take that sword
a ruby
and a Broad Sword blueprint
all right so we got four cells
I kind of want
yeah we need to work on those next
[Music]
all right there we go
fill this up
I don't like to load these screens man
I'm playing on my PC why do I have
loading screens
[Music]
oh
so it kind of stuns him a little bit
don't worry you can have some of some of
it too
ow
[Music]
thank you oh God oh God I need this
thing
yeah fairy that
[Music]
okay the survival tablet
I want to be as fast as we possibly can
[Music]
oh my God
I don't even know how I'm walking so
fast
foreign
mess with me
oh oh barely dodged that
no hell
what's up back
I'm nervous
foreign
with these people
oh
my heartbeat's going up a little bit
guys oh
I got to this quick enough where does
this go to
oh yeah oh
oh
okay
[Music]
okay I don't know how to get that though
oh okay so you could pick them up
I like these though
got a thousand bucks yeah
okay we good we good we got our health
back
we doing some work on here man
[Music]
and I got whatever this is
it's like a red so I'm assuming it's
like a legendary
man it's way stronger
oh what is this dude some Demon looking
dude now I got a new toy
oh no we ain't doing that we ain't doing
that
here hold this
[Music]
all right so I just gotta jump above
them real quick okay
yeah see look at this thing
all this power
[Music]
let me get that with
two
you ain't getting away
I see you
ah get up
get him
oh get him get him get him get him
oh it looked like he was gonna he was
gonna clap me if you could
let's just drink this let's not even
risk it
we're not risking getting hit
I feel like the power we have is worth
it
[Music]
we're not playing no more
we want blood
in the streets
wow
oh my God these Metro looking things man
ah
foreign
oh
oh man we got killed by the Metroid
thing
foreign
man I felt so strong too
I have no clue what this is for
eign
okay
[Music]
don't tell me
won't hurt my feelings
but I went through so much power to so
little power
we ain't playing
thank you
got the ice Shield
[Music]
and we can eat that
I'm not playing with you guys
look at that
stay stand no chance
[Music]
got ya Yahtzee
thank you
[Music]
an electric whip
yeah we're rolling with that
hey guys
now I got rage on you oh I didn't know
you could stop that
is it like the closer I am the more
damage I'll do
you like to know how that works
toxic sewer
what's toxic about the sewer
all right
yeah yeah yeah
we got eight cells
[Music]
man I really like this though
but I want
something a little bit faster
[Music]
okay so I dropped some kind of vial or
something
it explodes
I wonder if I could shoot it
all right what is this
hey you come here for a second
a little slow but you seem to understand
what I'm saying I lost I lost my room so
I'm a little stuck I need my room you
can see you wouldn't mind fighting me
for
what's in it for me
it's got to be something in it for me
look at these rats
I like the bleeding effect
foreign
dead
ow
oh what is this
nah I think I'm gonna let the the
bleeding kill you
oh God
yeah we're gonna let him die from that
laughs
[Music]
oh God I got one HP left
I'm struggling this will give me a
little HP oh it didn't give me nothing
it just raised my stats without doing
anything
why is he so fast
all right so I'm looking at it I've
already started the quest line to get to
it
uh but I have to find
I have to find him
somewhat uh
hold up something's happening
[Music]
dear prisoner
by this smile and what I definitely am I
think we can help each other meet me in
the series I'm restarting restocking for
food
[Music]
what is this
oh okay
[Music]
that's cool
I still don't know what those things up
there about
[Music]
hello I just arrived here I'm the new
doctor I noticed that you've been having
a hard time surviving on the island I'm
looking for a new again World
collaborator I've helped with some
experiment I call aspects
they are incredibly they are incredible
enhancements designed to make their
shows much stronger would you like to
try one it's free I owe you that much
considering that it developed them using
your core
um I mean some old stuff that I found
laying around to come back to attend to
develop a new aspect oh that's cool
[Music]
I haven't even instead I I can't find a
boss
[Music]
what is this
oh Hollow Knight they're showing other
indie games I like this this is really
good I like the fact that they're doing
this
there are more chapters not explaining
it's just a large picture of a nightclub
and blue plates and hordes and a title
Shovel Knight his shovel is especially
visible looks like
the reproducer of the painting on Hall
hotline yeah I like this this is cool
katana
yo
that's cool I really really really like
that
yeah we'll go with the electric wood for
right now
I like the electric whip it's just not
as strong though
yeah I was about to go back for that
I wonder if those bats are taking me to
Trevor
or Hector I don't know which one it is
probably all in my head though
yeah you thought you had me there didn't
you
infantry ball
look for some downward stairs going down
the castle skirt yeah that's that's what
I saw
so I mean let's go down let's see if we
can find it down
what is this
[Music]
what
that's weird
[Music]
oh that's cool
okay
[Music]
I really like it though not right now
gotcha
foreign
uh we don't want to go to the toxic
sewers
go up okay so that we have to go up all
right appreciate it man
[Music]
oh my God go up
oh right here
I request your help your hands are
disturbing anyway my quest is too
important for me to be picky evil is
making its back into the world you must
come with me in his heart and banish it
once more down the stairs you'll find a
path to the castle outskirts I'll meet
you there
all right
old castle outskirts
here we go guys here we go
give me one second guys
foreign
[Music]
let me go back to
this screen all right let's
oh so I can go in here okay
bunch of money
[Music]
bloody sword
a wolf trap
oh
[Music]
I probably should have got the the
damage
who is this
I am showing a master of magic Alchemy
is not really my strong suit but I still
might be able to help you make something
of those cells you carry
foreign all right so let's talk about
that you know clearly I'm not a hundred
percent aware of what's going what goes
on in the Castlevania franchise to a
degree uh but what I do like that I see
they did is it clearly seems like this
chick is part of that universe
and it's looking like they're using her
as an NPC instead of bringing the other
NPC here I like that I like that they're
you know they did something different
[Music]
if we want that health
uh definitely I really enjoyed the
Resident Evil remake demo I used to yeah
I I can't wait to get my hands on that
Resident Evil 4 demo
[Music]
all right here we go guys Castle
outskirt what goes in the shadow of the
cast could be way worse than the weeds
current time is two minutes
[Music]
oh this this music is lit
it sounds like Castlevania
[Music]
cross
we'll play
[Music]
oh oh it's a werewolf
we want that money
this music is lit guys
[Music]
oh metrovania little stuff right there
foreign
what is this
oh
got that Emerald key
[Music]
I'm not playing with you guys
you shout me punished
oh
[Music]
thank you
yeah I'm not playing
we have to stop Dracula
let him come back
he heard so many people last time
[Music]
this can't be him
difficult
[Music]
imagine that one's Dracula look what you
just did imagine if that was just
Dracula and you came up there stomping
on the door like that
he's like yeah who's in there it's it's
a coffin it's a coffin there can't be
much in there
oh it's a Dracula or Alorica I don't
know what you guys would call them
[Music]
later you know yeah it's just it's the
Sun
that's cool he's in here
[Music]
oh
take the aloe vera quickly okay I got
you
[Music]
oh man this thing's huge oh
oh
[Music]
oh look at that man
we gotta do it again nah this looks like
we're good
I like the whip man
I mess with the whip
[Music]
oh
man
that
that bone gave me a concussion
it looks like you just got to move up a
little bit if I am
[Music]
we cannot get hit by that again guys
thank you
[Music]
hey what is this
I need Dracula's son to hurry up and out
no
[Music]
I need some help
all right
[Music]
what is this
kind of drink from it
oh no I probably can't drink that
foreign
I really could have used Health this
Fountain could have been used for
something man
I can't believe you tried to hit me with
that that bow stop it
no
I was so not close to being there
I could feel
Dracula right around the corner not
really
I'm sure he was he was quite a bit away
I don't even know what that is
[Music]
I don't even know where that goes
oh God
give me my whip fast
[Music]
I want my whip back
I don't like that you guys took it
give me my whip back you got it nope
someone's got my damn whip
how
[Music]
please
there'll be hell to pay till I get my
whip back
I ain't playing with you guys
you guys want to live give me my whip
back
[Music]
you don't even have a whip
that's pathetic
how's the merchant not have what I need
[Music]
what the hell is this
okay that's not what I wanted but it's
something
I want my wet
[Music]
ow
I thought you'd not die
yeah yeah yeah
foreign
let's heal myself
it's not worth dying
not before I found my whip
you like this balanced blade though
fast
oh hold up
what's this we got some daggers
okay
I don't even know what those things do
we got to get back to Dracula's castle
I'm worried for the world
oh someone else got killed
[Music]
also there's a training room
been dead for a while
[Music]
we're not going to The Condemned
we're going to Dracula's castle
[Music]
we're worried about Dracula
he ruined the world once if we don't go
he's gonna do it again
oh I love this
hold back
yeah I don't know what
I like to burn
there you go
that's what I like go get more of that
hold that
let's get some blueprints
foreign
oh
oh this dude
got an emerald key
we got a frost large
downward attacks cover the ground with
flaming oil
[Music]
is this it
yeah so that's the oil
[Music]
I like that
so
all right all right that that's cool I
like the the combinations of stuff
oh my God the sewers
I like how everything's on the map
though
very detailed
very detailed game if I say so myself
um
we're good right here
get all the Scrolls
what do the Scrolls do
oh they increased stuff so what's the
difference between brutality objects
tactic tactic objects and survival
objects
oh at the bottom they're red oh
okay
Pier now
can attack while moving up and down
attack downwards will cause Airborne
because of you about
I don't like that
[Music]
us
I just wish that you could you could
have another speed
[Music]
every time every item has a category you
want to get item everything the same
color and always get the Scrolls of that
color
I assume there's a teleporters
Castle outskirts
we lit we going right back to it man we
got we got to take out Dracula
of course I definitely didn't make any
of those
I got 15. let's put 15 in the health
I like combos
foreign
[Music]
round two we won't get it this time
round two
Castle outskirts I lowered the bridge is
it still there uh no it's not that that
stuff
oh no it is
[Music]
this is a lot stronger than that other
one was
but shout out to that whip man it was it
was doing some work
[Music]
okay
if you have a red weapon that you want
to keep you want to build your other
items around that red item spreading
Scrolls red blue every level leaves you
way underpowered later on so pretty much
you want to stick to a similar build
because if you if you try to like space
it out you're going to be at a huge
disadvantage later on in the game
[Music]
thank you
look at that look at that oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh
there's something keeping me from going
in there
I wish there was a sprint button
it kind of bothers me very bad that
there's not a Sprint one
[Music]
how do I get down there
oh okay
[Music]
how do I get back up there
what is this
tastes like I don't know
I'm not gonna even try to figure it out
surprise
you filthy animal
I'm here
all right so pretty much
leveling that support level up the items
I have but it does look like there's a
little purple in that magic so but it
seems like for the most part it's red
[Music]
what you doing
did I give you guys permission to
breathe
[Music]
did you just teleport on me
don't do that
[Music]
thank you
don't teleport
[Music]
I gotta do all this again
got a little bit of uh dead so
[Music]
I gotta get to the top of that
oh okay gotcha
[Music]
we're going up
can I catch that thing jumping around
[Music]
I want to catch this thing
come here
[Music]
no reason to be scared of me
I have no clue what that is but I have
it
I have some form of a key
[Music]
that fire is really effective against
them
thank you
all right let's go back up
[Music]
we're going to the top of this Castle
this time
fighting those will be a little bit
harder about the whip
I don't think it's gonna be like a huge
problem I just got to learn their timing
[Music]
we already went up there once oh no no
go back up
[Music]
yeah get that way
over finished
[Music]
come break it into the door the front
door
this doesn't seem very
very smart to me though
oh man they're making me but I think
that will give me more health so I'm
gonna pick that
[Music]
let's kill you first
foreign
[Music]
oh
a visitor I started to lose hope Richard
become free of me
so that I could tell my needed I could
look out for myself I sit at kitty
caviar permission to give me the key
because we came back into your house
guess I have to thank you for anyone
free at last my cat's going to like you
don't forget to give him a little
scratch behind his ears for me I'll pack
without
Okay so
I guess that got me the outfit
[Music]
so you ID
okay so I'll probably be four for that
one okay
[Music]
drug who lost Castle
we made it to the castle chat we made it
to the castle Realm
and we didn't get here quick enough
[Music]
let's work on that
all right
thank you
[Music]
got a lot of Health chat we've sitting
here popping up almost 700.
we doing good things
fighting Dracula's castle right now
[Music]
what is that
oh
yeah I like that
foreign
yeah those things are weird
oh my God
got the ones above me raining down hell
off top of me
[Music]
and they
let's pop that red one
[Music]
I'm starting to learn this game a little
bit
[Music]
here
hold the fire buddy here hold the fire
catch yourself on fire
[Music]
stop doing that
no one gave you permission to revive
yourself
[Music]
okay I guess I'm not supposed to come
this direction yet
um it's called dead cells it's the
Castlevania
uh expansion
[Music]
oh yeah we ain't fighting you
you ain't even worth our time
here
both of you
fire
now this thing unfortunately you just
gotta kill this thing
if I catch this thing on fire
ah
there you go hold this
before
thank you
yo love catch yourself on fire oh the
yeah we we ain't messing with that
I think I will kill this one though
[Music]
foreign
oh my God stop it
[Music]
trying to catch people on fire and it's
hard when you doing that stuff
I got to get some of my health back
squirrel power
we're gonna keep going with that man
[Music]
oh
I got another health potion
[Music]
just in case
let's just drink that
I don't trust these things
[Music]
no no no no
fire might not do a lot to you
[Music]
they're an issue
take like a bunch of them like that
what is that
oh cross
Castlevania stuff
[Music]
hmm
gotta go back for that
[Music]
I'm getting
stronger and stronger guys
all right so there's still people over
here
well I mean I kind of ran a little bit
there for a minute
what an idiot
foreign
[Music]
yeah here you know the drill
thank you
that that thing doesn't seem to be weak
against fire too much
you know the drill
they all know the drill
[Music]
oh what's up buddy
buddy you look cold
[Music]
you look cold
ow
[Music]
Ed
oh no
[Music]
yeah we're not fighting that thing not
right now
we're gonna fight this thing first Dodge
through this and then fight that one
[Music]
oh it's an elite
oh oh my God
foreign
[Music]
I'm pretty hurt now though
unfortunately
[Music]
that fight took a lot out of me
we don't need anything green
okay I didn't grab something
thank you
something over there
oh is that it's this thing
I don't need this ice cream oh no
actually it's
it's just a regular move okay I can use
that
that's fine
I could use Health more than anything
right now though
[Music]
oh my God
oh I didn't know he was gonna swing at
me he thought he's gonna keep throwing
those those axes
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
that's the only way I have to really
fight them right now let's let that
recover
I need I need to be way more observant I
need to not underestimate these things
I need some of my health back
okay or you could just
completely mess that up
[Music]
oh God oh God oh God oh God
all right let's let's let that come back
the good thing is I could throw these
fires
oh oh no
oh
yeah
I ain't gonna lie to you guys I'm a
little defeated there
oh my arm
all right
[Music]
oh I'm so mentally drained after that
one
and the ball got me man
that bone got me
I don't think that was fair to be honest
with you
[Music]
hey
but it's square one with knowledge
and that's never truly Square One
[Music]
foreign
come on jump up there geez
[Music]
we got a Dracula to kill
we don't have time for all this
[Music]
oh I got that scroll I gotta get
we gotta go
you gotta go
[Music]
we got ice
we gotta go
[Music]
no
you don't offer me anything
go go go go go go
[Music]
try the The Condemned Place once then
we'll go back to the castle vein you
think I want to fight a boss like a
genuine boss man I really suck
oh
my God
[Music]
so the outfits you can unlock a magic
bow
let's put them all in these Spartan
sandals
[Music]
man I only have my phone
I feel a little bit more confident going
in here now
oh you can't even hurt that thing
oh
yeah wow
what's up
[Music]
go go go go go
oh purple we're going with survival
more health
need all the help we can get chat
[Music]
foreign
looks like
we can go over here
all right let's
let's get this going guys
let's just go back up
use this teleport to see if we can find
something
all right
I love how it stands them when you go
out the door
that attention to details nice
oh
[Music]
we're going down
was down here
all right so that's a teleporter
nothing really we can even buy currently
what is this
like how they dislike put something like
that in the game and just not explain
literally anything do you
[Music]
all right we go so far so far
foreign
[Music]
go all green and go with green weapons
is because like the massive amount of
like Health Reserve you can have
[Music]
probably should have picked a sword
man this thing does a lot of damage
[Music]
I'll try the green thing next
[Applause]
[Music]
oh that was close
no
[Music]
wasn't letting that happen
what is that
go down
oh God
get over here
oh
let's just drink it
foreign
I don't think fighting them is necessary
it's gonna be like a
mechanic to go like left to right
that I clearly don't possess currently
[Music]
so let's just go back up to the top
I have no clue what this is
[Music]
but I'm sure we'll find out eventually
he doesn't try to put me in that death
box
[Music]
thank you
where is this going
[Music]
okay I clearly don't have what I need to
get in there
I wonder if that'll kill me if I'm On
Top below that when it falls
it's so far man I'm really
I'm really feeling
this is an old game though too so I
can't really like put a lot into it I
really should have been playing this
game for a while to be honest with you
[Music]
I do like the Necromancer one
I feel like you have like more control
over what's going on
[Music]
ah ramp the ramparts
probably gonna get stomped here
foreign
[Music]
we're not trying to get killed already
there you go
um
was there a place where I can keep
falling
all right we're trying to kill this dude
fast
[Music]
I think this would be a good switch game
too if you really think about it
[Music]
further put your mind to it
oops
yeah we're going to get that new fire
move
doors with three circles take three boss
cells to open Boss says you're giving to
you after you defeat the hand of the
king or the queen if you have the queen
and the codc and they are used to
elevate the game's difficulty
[Music]
get this dude up here
okay
[Music]
ow
my God things are not going very well
for me
so hurt
let's drink one of these
[Music]
all right we found something
fire spinning blades at nearby enemies I
like that
I think that's the one I used at the
beginning yeah got to be close to it for
for you to use it though
ow
74.
okay
you gotta get rid of the mall cat
except for them I don't really care
about them
you need another one of these
oh
idiot
I hate that damn move
[Music]
let's go
man there's just nothing I could do
I was so focused on healing I got hit a
couple times
oh
I'd really like to fight a boss
like jeez
what did you gotta do to fight a boss
stupid
all right
[Music]
oh we got there fast
okay
[Music]
a nutcracker
we're taking this Nutcracker yo
[Music]
we got the Nutcracker
is there like a kicking we've had it
[Music]
I have a feeling this ain't going to be
as easy as it was the last time
last time I had more objects to come in
there with
this time not so much
[Music]
probably after this run we'll go into
the just chatting scene and and chat it
up for a couple minutes
before I call it a string
okay I don't like how slow this thing is
it's mad strong though I can't say it's
not
it's just I'm taking mad damage trying
to use it
I think it's more of a
it's more of a
[Music]
yeah it's got to be very careful when
you use this move
it is strong
[Music]
[Applause]
what is this move dude
so I'm like mad close range
but it pushes them back
[Music]
all that that hammer is green
I do like the hammer I just got to get
used to the timing
[Music]
I guess we'll go green
okay we could spend a little bit of
money
what is this
um
I guess just a dead end
it's MC Hammer time that's the way you
say it could be Phil
[Music]
foreign
thank you
I bet you I could have reached that
without
getting the spikes but it took a little
bit of damage but I think I could have
done it
[Music]
getting paid man ow
Ed
golden eye
I don't know man
[Music]
that's where I might
draw the line This golden eye
I ain't doing that you get out of here
I don't know what you guys think you're
doing
come here come here come here come here
get out of here come here
[Music]
what is that
a whip sword
oh
I had 39 cells too
I think that could have really worked
out for me
all right all right
you guys
um
I was definitely in the wrong with that
sales like you know it's not that I had
an issue with that cells or I didn't
like dead cells
it's just I personally like you know how
like enough time goes by where you feel
like
you know you should go back to a game
but you never do
uh that that's how I feel about dead
cells it's you know I knew that I should
have went back and played it but I knew
that I wouldn't
at that time I had no interest like none
so yeah I feel what you guys are saying
on that you know I do
uh but I do want to point out the game
was good like it's it's a very solid
experience and it's one of the few games
I think I've played uh because I played
it before just not a lot
it's one of the few games I've played
that I can honestly say I can see where
roguelike is appealing to people
because to me you know
it's not appealing to me I just don't
think it's appealing at all
and that's not saying anything bad about
it I just I personally have never seen
you know I liked Hades I felt like Hades
was a good one I feel like
Hades and dead cells so far
is showing where that genre could go and
how well it can be
if that makes sense to you guys
[Music]
but I enjoyed it man I think
it's kind of crazy that they they gave
you that's what I respect that they give
you the opportunity to make the game
harder I respect that
[Music]
because I do believe that a lot of
places these days
they're not doing that
[Music]
these days it's just pretty much like
unless the game is hard
we're not like it's either one or the
other and I feel like
companies do try their hardest to you
know balance that casual audience like I
don't I don't envy
people that have to balance that imagine
what it'd be like to like know that your
job and the success of your company can
be based on
getting newer people in your ecosystem
in the games that you make but at the
same time trying to respect the people
that are currently making your your
console
like I
I personally couldn't imagine
what that's like I think that that would
be very you know
very
anxiety like I could that's all I see is
anxiety
like imagine like Final Fantasy I feel
like was ruined by trying to appeal to a
casual audience
in
I don't think they did a good job
balancing it
and to this to this day where I'll still
play Final Fantasy maybe it's my fault
you know me me giving Final Fantasy such
uh buying all of them even though that I
know I'm probably not gonna like them
maybe that's giving them all the leeway
they need to like never try to appeal to
anything and just always keep doing
stuff you know maybe that's my fault and
I need to do better on that I need to
stay under my guns but I just love games
man I love playing games and to me
even though I there's a good chance I'm
not gonna like it I owe it to myself to
at least try foreign
[Music]
they want you to take a whole hour like
a whole hour
[Music]
when
you guys gotta excuse me I gotta find
out when this particular
interview is happening at PAX East
[Music]
gotta figure it out man
all right looks like
[Music]
5 P.M to 6 p.m
but let me look
what day is that
Friday
[Music]
oh yeah there it is
okay
yeah so I think what I might do this
year
because I've never done it is once we
get closer to the release
maybe that like two or three days before
I actually leave like we I leave on a
Wednesday or or I think next Wednesday I
think it's the 22nd I'll leave I leave
in the morning shout out to to the
girlfriend she's taking me to the
airport love that woman love that woman
uh so maybe Monday maybe a week from
today what I'll do is I will get the
list of all the games that we're going
to look at and then we'll watch trailers
go over them I think that's what we'll
do next Monday
foreign
you know I'll make thumbnails live you
know we'll really we'll chat it up man
find out what games you guys excited for
what kind of questions would you want me
to ask
[Music]
it'll be next next Friday by next Monday
probably start at 5 p.m because I like
starting Universal around the same time
[Music]
I would do it this week but we still
have a lot of appointments that haven't
been confirmed yet
[Music]
oh
I'm looking right now
um
I might have to ask hog about this
particular game
I really want to
to watch
[Music]
all right all right so hold up let's
I'll give you guys one game before I get
off here
that I really because I'm still talking
to them about what day is good
well actually I'll save it all for next
week I'll save it all for next week man
but you know I appreciate it for coming
through here
uh you know it was it was a great stream
I I think that dead cells got something
going on for them and I think they need
a really Captivate on that kind of
gameplay when they make a sequel and uh
you know until next time this is
gamiatic to my